what do you think of the saying you get
more bees with honey they actually asked
to leave this too but it's not here
you get more bees with honey I always I
always actually heard you catch more
flies with honey than with vinegar but
it's the same idea and it's something I
I agree with I mean obviously this comes
down to the r-word relationships and
always what I'm trying to do is I'm
trying to build the relationships so I'm
gonna put out the honey you know I'm
gonna put up the honey mm-hmm the carrot
is is is preferable to the stick which
is another way of saying that the reward
the good stuff the soso yeah totally
that that absolutely works better now
you can give people too much honey and
now they get type 2 diabetes they get
lazy they get out of shape and they
don't work anymore right so you can't
you gotta be that's that's the that's
the dichotomy that you need to balance
as leader not being too hard but not
being too soft not be too aggressive but
being aggressive enough
that's the dichotomy but the bottom line
is you need to treat people well that's
what you need to do you need to not
spoil them but give them respect and
build the relationships in if you make
that your goal but what I work with all
these different companies you know I'm
gonna say listen make your goal with
this person that you're having a problem
make your goal to build a relationship
that make that your goal mm-hmm when
they say something negative say
something positive when they want to
blame something on you say yeah you're
right it's my fault build a relationship
with the person that's gonna strengthen
the team is gonna be thousand times
infinitely better than having the
antagonistic relationship with somebody
so and also you know when you're leading
with vinegar when you're leading with
fear and you're leading with your you're
beating pee
but with a stick that does not work out
good in the long run do you have to have
consequences sometimes yeah but the team
that is following somebody because they
want to do their best for that leader is
gonna beat the team that is doing things
only because they're scared of the
leader right yeah
they if they're trying to avoid the
stick that's gonna be where they operate
in they're gonna operate enough to avoid
the sticks yeah because really that's
the goal to avoid the stick there's no
honey
you're not real above and beyond yeah I
think you said something very wise in
office space what does he say in his
little review he got hypnotized
did you watch I've watched it a million
times so so he gets hypnotized all right
so now he tells the truth or he doesn't
care you know about things so he's like
he's real open and honest he goes into
this little review which is supposed to
be this kind of tense thing and they say
like what's up you know some don't ask
him some stuff and he's like it's a it's
a problem of motivation like what you
know we're not it if I get you know all
the seats so he's explaining it too and
then he's like okay if I'm if I'm scared
of you know whatever this punishment
from my boss or whatever no I'm just
gonna work hard enough not to get fired
and but that's true that's absolutely
true so yeah like these kids who only
get scolded you know they don't get like
compassion and compliment and support
you know they only get scolded a lot of
times I mean there's a lot more to it
but a lot of times they're just gonna do
the minimum and clearly and not go get
schooled in too far in the other
direction gets spoiled
yeah yep and the dangerous part about
getting giving to like going too far in
the other direction how you put it is
you don't prepare them like they they
wind up when they're on their own like
they're not prepared for like there's
like tough part yeah and there's a lot
of good parts in life man but those
tough parts they're there too so if
you're not prepared for me gonna get
jacked for lack of a better term that's
the correct term actually